revendre tout ce qui traîne dans les
placards louer son matériel qui ne sert
que quelques jours par an où acheter
seulement des objets d'occasion de
nouveaux modes de consommation
apparaissent et vous les vieux objets
vous en faites quoi
que dirais tu as poubelles pour faire
les ventes sur internet
je conserve ça m'arrive que je t'aimais
je conserve frédol cadeaux
avec la crise le marché de l'occasion et
de la location explose les magasins
spécialisés affiche des résultats
records mais c'est surtout sur internet
que ça se passe rien que sur la toile
l'occasion représenterait un marché de 7
milliards d'euros
une vente sur deux serait réalisé sur le
net car maintenant on peut tous loués en
quelques clics
cette semaine avec combien ça coûte
l'hebdo vous saurez tout tout tout sur
la deuxième vie des vieux objets
rg retraité il a bien vécu mais
aujourd'hui il est devenu très économe
voilà j'ai assez un un sèche-linge que
j'ai payé 200 euros ne cherchez pas chez
serge qu'ils aient payé un euro tout et
d'occasion des tableaux que gp56 euros
depuis dix ans il n'a plus jamais
acheter du neuf ce sont des cas gpi 5 6
ans mais c'est de sa dernière
acquisition dont il est le plus fier
et en plus ils n'avaient presque encore
jamais servi voilà c'est le lit qu'elle
était enveloppée dans un carton tout et
que j'ai payé 350 euros
j'ai acheté neuf compter un minimum le
doubs notre retraité touche une petite
tension de 1100 euros par mois du coup
pour s'équiper
ils se rendent dans un magasin situé
juste en bas de chez lui ici on ne vend
que des produits d'occasion et serge qui
est connu comme le loup blanc décédé à
trois euros
des dizaines de téléphones mobiles à
moins de 20 euros et des téléviseurs à
prix donnés ici rien ne se jette tous
heureusement dans ce magasin on rachète
cachent les objets des particuliers pour
peu qu'il soit en bon état serge veut
justement revendre son appareil photo et
c'est frédéric le gérant du magasin qui
va l'expertisé tu as une idée du prix
qu'ils souhaiteraient le vendre
ou en tirer entre 70 et 80 11 nov
l'appareil photo vaut pas loin des 200
euros on va pouvoir le revendre avec la
carte c'est la housse une sombre où on
en vend notre commission on peut donner
70 euros en espèces tellement tard serge
est content il repart avec 70 euros en
liquide
si c'était très intéressant d'avoir des
sous sans s'ennuyer en quelques minutes
en cinq minutes que j'avais l'argent
l'occasion fait le larron mais la bonne
affaire c'est le magasin qu'il l'a fait
frédéric remet l'appareil photo
immédiatement en vitrine à 119 euros
soit 49 euros plus cher on gagne de
l'argent bien tout simplement rendre le
produit plus cher qu'on l'a achetée donc
avec une marge de 30 à 50% plus cher
avec la crise ces magasins ont poussé
comme des champignons
roger a monté 64 franchise dans toute la
france et cet ancien cheminot pèse
aujourd'hui 51 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui il vient inspecter l'autre
magasin de frédéric qui vient d'être
entièrement rénové
on voulait rentrer tous les soirs
important de la sécurité
donc on continue après un rapide tour du
propriétaire roger semblent satisfaits
mais ce qui l'intéresse c'est les
résultats
les travaux ont coûté près de 80000
euros roger attendait retour sur
investissement est vite mois après qu'on
a
l'augmentation importante de l'ordre
diana 30 à 40 30 ça cartonne tellement
que roger ouvre un nouveau magasin par
mois aujourd'hui tous les rêves lui sont
permis il pense même exporter son modèle
dans toute l'europe
la crise n'a pas été un frein pour nous
et vous rejet mais quelle inconscience
mensuellement
je sais pas
les magasins de cases de roger font un
carton mais désormais il doit faire face
à un concurrent qui ne coûte pas un euro
pour se monter les sites de vente sur
internet
natacha est une adepte de l'achat
d'occasion sur la toile mais depuis peu
elle est aussi devenue une redoutable
vendeuses des téléphones portables un
ordinateur et des consoles de jeux
plus rien ne part à la poubelle elle a
la bosse des affaires
si on veut les revendre dans des
magasins spécialisés
c'est vrai que ils se prennent une marge
assez importante alors que sur ce site
là on choisit son prix il suffit d'être
un tout petit peu plus compétitifs que
les hôtes et l'achat est effectuée
rapidement au total natacha pu gagner
près de 1200 euros avec ses ventes
elle s'est tellement prise au jeu que
romain son mari s'inquiètent de voir
tous disparaître dans la maison mais des
fois j'ai rentré c'est vrai que bad et
qu'il y ait quelque chose on n'a plus
besoin vous y allez hop on lui met en
vente et puis ça fait des sous c'est
derrière cette vitrine
que se cache le site préféré de natacha
ça ne paye pas de mine et pourtant avec
deux millions de visiteurs chaque mois
le business de paul et ses amis marche
plutôt bien
va percevoir une commission sur chaque
produit vendu de mission qui va de 10 à
13% en fonction des produits et en
fonction du prix de vente
mais certaines de nos questions
dérangent sur les résultats de
l'entreprise paul à ordre de rester très
discret en termes de communication dont
nous communiquons pas un chiffre
d'affaires ces raisons confirme en
concurrence nos concurrents ne
communiquent pas leurs chiffres
d'affaires nous avons une communiquons
pas le nôtre ça a marché
discutez en france il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs qui s'intéressent à l'achat
vente sur internet
l'occasion est un marché on parle de 7
milliards d'euros en termes de vols pas
de chiffre d'affaires attendu sur
l'occasion pour les années à venir
donc forcément c'est un marché assez
compétitifs pour se démarquer de la
concurrence cette société qui n'a même
pas 10 ans a tout misé sur la sécurité
des transactions des tentatives arnaque
nicolas on décèle une quinzaine par jour
la plus classique des petits malins qui
tentent de contourner le site pour
éviter de payer la commission ou alors
carrément d'escroquer les internautes
les gens qui souhaitent procéder à ce
genre de vente frauduleuse vont essayer
de contourner notre système en diffusant
leurs coordonnées adresse e-mail
téléphone de manière à recevoir un
paiement direct d'un acheteur pour bien
entendu ne rien envoyer en sucre pour
chaque transaction nicolas débloque le
paiement une fois l'acheteur satisfait
et jamais avant mais maintenant
l'occasion a du souci à se faire
la nouvelle tendance est à la location
il n'en a pas l'air comme ça patrice
mais il ya encore quelques années il
avait les cheveux longs il aimait faire
la fête et il était dj aujourd'hui il a
un travail très sérieux mais il refuse
de se séparer de tout son matériel sono
est un mixage
résultat son petit appartement et envahi
couloir avec la sono les enceintes
qu'elles sont basses et une aisance
entre conte mais également sur pied
alors le plaquage et plus de sono que
d'autres choses ou de l'humeur
stroboscopes laser machine patrice en a
pour plus de 7000 euros de matos puis
comme j'ai pas
à cette passe ici je n'ai aussi mis dans
la cave
plutôt que de revendre son matériel il a
eu une autre idée
le loup est sur un site entièrement
dédié à la location entre particuliers
par exemple cette sono jaloux 60 euros
par jour sur ses 60 euros en fait je
vais toucher au final 51 euros la
différence en fait va couvrir
l'assurance du produit plus la
commission pour le site de location
donc en fait chaque fois qu'on fait une
location l'objet est assuré contre le
vol et la casse sa passion l'encombrent
toujours autant mais maintenant elle lui
rapporte un peu d'argent 1000 euros par
an en moyenne ce matin elle c'est pour
faire plaisir donc l'objectif n'est pas
forcément de l'argent mais au moins
d'amortir le matériel le pelephone pour
trouver aujourd'hui il accueille
karamoko elle organise un anniversaire
surprise pour sa meilleure amie pour lui
en mettre plein la vue
elle a décidé de louer tout un jeu de
lumière à patrice je fais comme ça nous
a enlevé le film de couleur vous changé
et vous remettrez consorts dif les
projecteurs et la boule à facettes façon
discothèques ne lui coûte que 28 euros
donc à ce prix là c'est une affaire
j'ai fait quelques devis et puis j'en ai
facile donc pour 90 euros dont un devis
que j'ai fait là et j'en avais pour 87
euros une petite signature au bas d'un
contrat et le tour est joué
karamoko repart avec son matériel
derrière ce business de la location il
ya un expert de la net-économie marc
simoncini
il a fait fortune avec son site de
rencontres meetic
aujourd'hui il à 100 millions d'euros
investir dans les start up
il croit tellement au succès de la
location qu'il a misé 2 millions d'euros
dans la société de gary mais ce n'est
pas un mécène et ils veillent au grain
c'est très bien et alors ça on en est ou
sur le les objets en location sur le
même objet là on est en haut mais on est
à 150 nouveaux objets et c'est une
croissance de combien sa séquence
profond de ses 15 % par mois
marc simoncini est ce que l'on appelle
un homme qui a du flair quand je
commence à ressentir quelque chose je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens au même
moment qu'ils ressentent ça et je me dis
que tôt ou tard les gens préféreront
louer les objets plutôt que d'acheter la
dernière fois qu'il a misé sur une
entreprise comme celle ci il a touché le
jackpot 25 millions d'euros 35 fois sa
mise de départ
avec internet on peut louer des objets
mais maintenant on peut carrément se
louer soi même c'est patrick qui a eu
l'idée il ya un an
un soir au restaurant avec des amis
alors que sa baby sitter venait de lui
faire faux bond pour les installe
plantage de l'abbé misse était le lave
vaisselle qui s'est mis à fuir
l'installation la cuisine et on s'est
dit qu'on pourrait inventer un site où
des personnes comme nous conte des
besoins et des galères pourrez poster
des annonces et on pourrait trouver des
personnes qui proposera les services et
qui pourrait répondre à nos besoins
vous avez du temps libre un don
particulier il suffit de proposer ses
services
d'un autre côté vous avez une galère
vous fait une annonce le site met les
gens en contact et pour l'instant c'est
gratuit je pense que d'ici la fin de
l'année on fera payer le service et on
proposera de prélever quelques euros
soit une commission sur le montant de la
prestation soit un abonnement pour les
prestataires qui veulent répondre aux
annonces ce site internet
françoise ne peut plus s'en passer
bonjour la trouver facilement sa ba
ouais aujourd'hui françoise embauché
mousse un peintre artisan voilà
l'étendue des dégâts
elle veut faire repeindre ses toiles
elle à la pièce à refaire françoise a
trouvé mousse après avoir passé une
annonce sur le site et en à peine deux
jours elle a reçu huit de vie de
professionnels et de particuliers à tous
les prix j'ai choisi parce que quand
j'ai bien aimé son annonce que tu es
assez explicite qui m'a donné confiance
puisqu'il va donner son numéro de
téléphone tout de suite il était bien
noté aussi parce que c'est un site sur
lequel on peut les noter et donc il
avait un petit coeur favori donc ça m'a
ça m'a donné confiance je les appelais
et le jour même
et bah vous voyez deux jours après les
lifes les faits la peinture effet les
travaux ça vous coûte cher ça me coûte
80 euros c'est trois à quatre fois moins
cher qu'une entreprise qui a pignon sur
rue et tout le monde y trouve son compte
ça permet aussi des géants l'un dédié en
période de crise des gens qui ont
vraiment besoin de travailler donc ça
j'aime bien le concept et puis des
professionnels et des semi
professionnels ou des gens qui sont à la
retraite et qui ont besoin de revenus
complémentaires
j'aime bien l'idée de solidarité que ce
site mousse lui est un auto entrepreneur
mais avec la crise les clients se
faisait rare pour s'en sortir il s'est
inscrit sur ce site il ya un an et
depuis il enchaîne les contrats via son
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner
oui ce problème et vous gagnez bien
votre vie grâce aux six gagnais bien ma
vie je sais pas mais ça me fait à peu
près un salaire de 1500 euros net par an
trois heures plus tard les toilettes de
françois sont comme neuves ramé le
contraste est saisissant
voilà bien des travaux qui ne prennent
pas de retard un plombier que l'on n'a
pas besoin de réserver un mois al avance
le bonheur c'est parfois simple comme un
coup de pic